governor jon corzine governor a great
state of New Jersey
I think there's no avoiding that the
major issue that is going to impact
everyone's life in America is the
economy have to get that stabilized we
have to get it out of free fall into a
position where it begins to recover and
so all decisions I think in the short
run have to be focused on trying to get
our economy going so that our people our
citizens can restore their confidence in
the direction of the country can never
walk away from our responsibilities in
the international arena we have two wars
a hundred and sixty thousand troops in
harm's way as we sit here at this moment
in time so it can't take the take his
eye off of our international
responsibilities than it in fact it
links back to our economy because if we
were able to thoughtfully and carefully
bring some of our troops home and have a
less lessened investment in some of the
things that we're doing in our overseas
operations it would help our economy at
home so I think he has to give that
great effort and then I think you know
the the overall issue with regard to our
energy independence and protecting the
globe from the build-up of carbon all of
those issues come together
I think we have to get focused on the
real economy from the basic elements of
housing markets financing markets in
general so that credit begins to flow
first thing I probably be doing is ask
the President to make sure that we
changed our bankruptcy laws so that
there could be renegotiation of
mortgages between the lender and
borrower in a organized in some
straightforward way second thing I'd be
pushing to make sure that we were
finding the way to put money into
keeping people in their homes either
direct loans to the individuals so they
continue to make payments or a
restructuring of the loans themselves
the fact is we won't stabilize the
wholesale financing markets the toxic
products that have been created on
leverage CDOs the kinds of things that
people have talked about in the
mortgage-backed security market that are
causing thanks so much problem unless we
actually stabilize the underlying
housing market in the mortgage market
that is a part of that
first thing you have to do any time you
have a tough situation is talk openly
and frequently with the audience that is
going to be the receiver of the changes
that you have to take or make to address
the problem you need to make sure that
you're fully in communication about what
the nature the problem is and what it is
that you believe you need to be doing
and that needs to be very clear and you
need to be repeating that over and over
again as far and broadly as you can so
that people understand what is impacting
their lives I think actually
communications a lot of it but also not
avoiding the problem you just have to go
at it and the tougher it gets the more
you have to be direct at addressing the
problem because if you don't there's a
cumulative momentum to the sort of
negative patterns that develop whether
it's in business or whether it's in
government and economics